judge Brett Cavanaugh says he's not
going anywhere in a very unusual public
defense of his fitness to serve on the
Supreme Court he strongly denied
allegations of sexual misconduct from
Christine Blasi Ford and Deborah Ramirez
during a TV interview last night he used
extremely personal information to claim
he is not that kind of person
president Trump then accused Democrats
of trying to destroy Cavanaugh with
quote an array of false accusations the
likes of which have never been seen
before Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
where we'll hear from Cavanaugh and Ford
on Thursday Nancy good morning good
morning and Republican leaders say they
are going forward with that hearing
despite the new allegations in fact they
say they may hold a vote on his
confirmation in the Judiciary Committee
as early as Friday with his wife sitting
at his side Cavanaugh said he looks
forward to clearing his name I'm not
going anywhere
judge Brett Kavanaugh had a message for
his critic stand stuck to it I am
looking for a fair process just asking
for a fair process I want a fair process
where I can defend my integrity
Cavanaugh discussed for the first time
whether he knew Christine Blasi Ford I
may have met her we did not travel in
the same social circles she was not a
friend not someone I knew he denied
forcing himself on her or anyone
I've never sexually assaulted anyone not
in high school not ever
he also denied Deborah ramirez's claim
that he exposed himself to her at a Yale
University party never did any such
thing the other people alleged to be
there don't recall any such thing lawyer
Michael avenatti says he has a client
who saw Kavanagh and his high school
friends target multiple girls for sexual
assault when the American people hear
from her they will determine as I have
that she is to be believed Cavanaugh
called that claim outrageous I did not
have sexual intercourse or anything
close to sexual intercourse in high
school or for many years thereafter
through all these years that are
jr. a virgin that's correct Cavanaugh
insisted he was not a rowdy teen was
focused on academics and athletics going
to church every Sunday at Little Flower
working on my service projects and
friendship but his yearbook page
repeatedly referenced drinking and in a
statement his former Yale roommate
reportedly described Kavanagh as a
notably heavy drinker who became
aggressive and belligerent when he was
very drunk
James Roche admits he did not observe
the incident Ramirez describes but he
says he believes her it's really hard to
believe this is not consistent with
Macbeth
Cavanaugh's wife Ashley said she has
struggled to explain all of this to her
kids
we told them at the very beginning of
this process this will be not fun
sometimes and just remember you know
your Kavanagh said the president told
him yesterday
top Republicans suggested this is all
part of a conspiracy this shameful
shameful smear campaign has hit a new
low Christine Blasi Ford's attorneys
responded to those remarks by the
Senate's Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
they said that they were inconsistent
with the Senate Judiciary Committee's
pledge to provide forward with a fair
and credible process Norah
all right Nancy thank you